hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
with the lovely and talented mariah
garcia she was on here a few months ago
I went on her channel a long time ago
had some delicious tacos she just put up
a vlog recently actually you guys should
go check it out hey Mariah did you watch
any shows when you were a kid No
Wow terrible segue for this episode
today yeah you're an improv yes well
today we're gonna watch from a YouTube
channel called Screen Rant they're an
awesome movie channel they have a list
video here ten subtle messages and kid
shows that parents wouldn't approve of I
probably wrote some of these let's check
it out people one of our favorite
pastimes as kids was watching our
favorite cartoon Adam areare most the
time our parents monitored what we
watched but even then there was some
subtle messages and innuendos that
slipped through the cracks
you know which ones stay tuned and find
out but before we read make sure to hit
that subscribe button stay up to date
with all the latest content on subscribe
before you know their content yes what
feature film these movies are showing
mine at the end of this video the show
had some very creative adventures the
babies went on but we also got to know
the parents and their personality just
like when we were kids
sometimes the adult dialogue and moments
got lost on us but looking back there
are some moments in the show that we are
happy that we didn't get like when
Tommy's grandpa tells the kids he rented
them some movies Reptar come home and
Reptar redux he then mentions he rented
his personal favorite lonely space
which is for after they go to pen but
the title like that and the fact that
the kids have to be asleep for it we're
pretty sure but only space mixes very
adult film you know what we need the
Powerpuff Girls accent I love the power
spice and everything to a whole new
level when they created a story about a
professor who wanted to create the
perfect little girl when he was mixing
the ingredients professor utonium
accidentally broke a bottle of Chemical
X into the mix and created the superhero
trio Blossom Bubbles and Buttercup yeah
so they made a friend named Robin do
they have over their house or a plating
after the professor introduces himself
bubbles goes on to mention that he made
them in his laboratory by accident well
what can I say that's a mature joke he
has become the norm for television we
usually trust Eric likes to have
something to watch when it comes to
cartoons we know they're always child
friendly right wrong Maya the bees show
on Netflix that was created by Studio
100 animation it was based on a German
children's book series first published
in 1912
so how harmful could it really be well
it so happens that a few parents noticed
a crude drawing of the male anatomy and
one of the scenes a couple of palms took
hosting a screen shot on social media to
show that the image was an episode no
not make any edits to the image if try
and search for the episode now it has
since been removed why how and why this
valid image was added to an otherwise
kid-friendly show what was really the
point that should definitely not be an
easter egg the parents
been happy to find her I wanted to cover
the roof of my mouth
it's what it is just about ever seen in
this show and dandelions much you wonder
how it got approved but to be honest
watching this show as an adult you
realize two things one you probably
shouldn't have watched this as a kid and
to you probably relate to this show a
lot more than you should
Bronco is modern light reflected the
struggles of adulthood young wallaby had
to deal with a scary boss the
tribulations of dating and even taking
some awful jobs like being a late-night
phone sex operator find jobs he comes
across an ad for a specialty phone
operator it cuts to him holding up a
phone saying that the place is called
you one-on-one hotline and next to him
is a set of love I would say to be hot
be naughty and Wow more explaining
doesn't
that jingle is Val victorious it's time
to make it shine friends the show
Victorious follows kids who go to an art
and performing school the main circuit
friends are all heavily into music and
sang recognize the show is the place
where miss ariana grande lovable Cat
Valentine
and let's face it Marisol in that show
this show is more so directed towards
teens but as we know kids also watch
them this show also had its share of
naughty jokes and innuendos for example
in the episode a Christmas story the
Hollywood art students are celebrating
the holiday Wow Andre is freaking out
because he got a bad grade on a
Christmas song he wrote in class
comes into class upset and asked his
fellow classmates how does a person go
from an 8 to a deep I'm sorry Jade
Baskin she didn't even look up very
hilarious joke about boob size gross if
you're curious he got his grave change
to an a after the team joined forces and
performed his song thank God SpongeBob
SquarePants
those are these funny fans chances are
you've noticed abuse someone in a
prepare in there some are purposeful
nudges others we aren't so sure about
but let's talk about the episode by
pretty Seymour's mid recall that
spongebob ends up with a beautiful wild
sea horse so he ends up calling mr. e at
one point mr. e ends up and work with
spongebob tries to hide her but fails
mr. Krabs makes it clear that she is a
wild animal and can't be in the
restaurant spongebob ends up tying
around front to the Krusty Krab a couple
of fish comes by and assume that mr. e
is a coin-operated kid ride so naturally
he begins looking for where to put the
coin
[Applause]
[Music]
now let's think about that first Wow we
would possibly put a coin into and
elicit that sort of reaction for mr. e
we snob I know this is a part when you
get you something it's a weird situation
the amazing world of gumball dad one
episode you Kara
I'm sorry Darwin calls out gumball for
being predictable so he runs over to
hotdog guy and a hugs I'm out of nowhere
Hey next day hotdog guy and gumball run
into each other in the hall and
awkwardly honk because as gumball
explains it can't daehan someone once
you hug them another day goes by and
they hug each other instead of talking
they awkwardly hum a tune and walk away
from each other after a few more awkward
encounters gumball invited hotdog guy
over or asleep that night they're both
sleeping in a tent in the backyard
that's hot dog guy snores gumball takes
his quilt off to relax but hotdog
unknowingly puts his hand on gumball he
tries to move it away he ends up
accidentally crawling on top of it hot
dog guy wakes up and screams internally
we see their figures silhouetted from
outside the tent as they hum their
awkward songs this looks totally
questionable from outside the 10 fans
have pointed out that this looks a bit
inappropriate Animaniacs nerds
remember the Animaniacs the Warner Bros
cartoon about the Warner Brothers and
the Warner sister dot
is one that 90s kids aren't very
familiar with oe
do you remember all the sexual innuendos
and ordered on inappropriate oh yeah
the sake of his list it shows one that
made us cringe looking back on when
Yakko asked dot to dust for prints she
misunderstands it comes back carrying
the singer no no fingerprints oh how did
this even make it on television our
parents allow us to watch it we can't
believe this actually aired for kids to
watch
wait Animaniacs Hodgins you can remember
no I missed it surely it doesn't explain
to me after Cartoon Network makes some
awesome show our favorite shows because
the show is geared more towards teens or
older kids the things of the show are
always a little more mature which also
meant the occasional giggle inducing
comments like when the Teen Titans get
sent a cardboard box of puppets that
look like the Titans the puppet King
emerges and activates his controller
which transfers their souls into their
puppets or that beast boy and Robin
admire their puppets and Robin remarks
and how accurate they are yeah they've
got all the details just right
speak for yourself it seems like they
didn't all of Beast Boy right TMI be coy
I'm missing so much
you probably remember that it too was
full of some inappropriate moments that
we didn't quite understand numbers of
that one what happens in a part two
episode called nuclear confusion as per
usual didi isn't involved in ruining
Dexter's day he creates the ultimate
reading lame and didi steals the power
source but of course the Power Core is
also an hour away from melting down and
destroying the earth naturally didi has
not made it easy for him to get the
power source back she leaves him clues
involved eating all the pies that mom is
making the clues lead him to go next
door he asked the neighbour lady if she
has his source
she laughs it off and asked if he wants
cookies she bends over after she drops
one of the cookies and he sees that on
her bum I think we need to explain the
objectification of matter on arere do we
what you just want to know how didi was
able to write that on the neighbor lady
Wow there you have it those messages and
kids cartoons the parents wouldn't
approve of what you think are there any
we missed
which one's did you find the most
shocking let us know in the comments
below let you know right now is the
answer to the emoji quiz did you get it
let us know you haven't already be sure
to subscribe to Screen Rant and stay up
to date with the latest videos bye for
now thanks grant that was a cool video
so tea time is what happened in Teen
Titans they have the action figures when
Teen Titan is saying how they got all
the detailing right I was looking at
Robin if I had a puppet that would have
been very accurate to me I would have
been like yep it's just as disappointing
as always Wow I mean some of these
messages are pretty racy I mean it's
just from the very beginning but the
rugrats one with the grandpa it sounds
like he's gonna go watch pornographic
material afterwards and you would expect
that from a grandpa he's a single
grandpa right I didn't watch Rugrats did
you yeah it was he married I don't know
if if he was a widow
yeah or he was just a single guy had a
lot of children out of wedlock in this
kid show oh yeah when they're like
making love in the tent
looks like that at least and it's a hot
dog yeah that is pretty graphic hours to
do those animations so you know what you
do you know and the penis one on the oh
that be show whatever the hell this show
was I've never heard I had the beat the
my the B one is just not subtle at all
no like The Little Mermaid cover and
stuff like that's like oh yeah we're
like whining we're since sex or
something in the wind it's bad that's
subtle and you have to really pay
attention to it's the same kids do we
draw penises in the bathroom I'm
graffiti or like binders those are the
ones I grow up to do this like yeah
that's pretty nuts yeah actually the one
that was a little bit surprising to me
was when Powerpuff Girls when the
professor is talking with that little
girl she's like yeah I made them by
accident the little girl says I was an
accident too that's a rather mature but
that's I don't know it says a lot
especially for a little too all the know
that I knew I was an accident when you
were a little kid I probably yeah at
least like in elementary splaine's the
emotional reactive ways you have now
because you grew up with this traumatic
house a you resident I don't think it's
traumatizing I think it all depends
sometimes in accidents a positive thing
something that like I feel like parents
try to keep a little bit secretive from
their kids sometimes until they're older
it's like if I kids adopted it'll tell
them sometimes later yeah but I guess
it's not that bad
you have put things in perspective
so he was like he made it clear that he
was not expecting to have more children
did he use it as a guilt factor no no
sometimes he didn't have as much energy
as like my friend's dad's you know to
like do activities and stuff so a
community so just by hey accident the
Animaniacs point I was really slow to
catch but then after you explained it to
me fingerprints that that is pretty
vulgar
it's a plan
I don't think it's that bad I mean it's
kind of implying that the girl animated
his sister fingerprints which we've all
just wanted to do want to but then she
felt like she had to which makes it even
worse she capitalized on why it's
terrible that makes for a much better
video I'm surprised number one is dad's
trophy although it's on the ass that
wasn't his mom though that was the
neighbor yeah that's pretty bad
so is implying that the dad's having an
affair with a neighbor
Wow I think that's the worst part if it
was the wife I'd be like I I do want to
be dad's trophy in the future I have I
have that written on my on my ass my
girlfriend wrote it for me yeah yeah she
calls herself daddy yeah it's a weird
let's say we're serious cuz it makes for
a more interesting video who'd you say
that yeah quality out of here man you
got to give her the man power position
some of these aren't too bad some you
like the Ariana Grande show Victorious
when this how do you go from A to D it's
a funny joke to me and it's a teen show
and it's puberty's doesn't need to be so
secretive yeah I remember I had I had
boobs before I was a teenager I was a
fatter and then I became a teenager and
I got taller and I went from like a D to
an A so I was like happy about that they
you reversed I reversed
yeah yeah yeah I don't think any girl
really wants big boobs either I just
thought I'd throw that out there you
know give you nothing to work off of
there's nothing to say after that what
was that one show though you said you've
seen it the one where he's having phone
sex what is this show I've never seen it
this is a kid show this seems like such
an inappropriate show clearly having
that's that's not subtle at all
yes be ha be naughty bit curious these
are adults who are writing these kids
shows they get bored and sometimes they
think they can get away with a vulgar
joke you know like when I was a little
kid I never noticed [ __ ]
one like they had a vulgar joke but then
I think sometimes when they do these
little things these innuendos I feel
like they do it because they're adult
and they know that parent you're
watching you when you take your kid or
film or you're like watching your kids
out to the jokes for you you need not
finish you need a dirty joke once in a
while yeah dirty to me dirty to me show
I don't know why parents we get so upset
are they thinking that their kids gonna
see this and then somehow it's gonna
mess with their subconscious and then
down the road we'll psychologically mess
them up maybe it's true what's happened
many times my dad showed me showgirls
when I was six years old and it's
changed me that was a kids movie I
highly recommend it for all children of
watch it's turned me into a great
confident man anyway guys you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our vids is up we have a
patreon weekly video responses
full-length video responses to Q&A is
full-length TV show reactions and
reviews and other stuff but more
importantly make sure to follow Mariah
Garcia on the social medias she has a
youtube channel she has an Instagram
give it Twitter too right I got it
she's funny she's got a Twitter she she
thinks she's funny I know I'm funny he
made me laugh thanks for ah